s'il ya bien une civilisation qui a
marqué l'imaginaire romantique
occidentale c'est celle des mayas cécité
100 habitants engloutis par la
végétation ces temples abandonné aux
hiéroglyphes mystérieux sont devenues
l'archétype de la découverte
archéologique et ont connu une postérité
parfois assez improbable bonjour à tous
et bienvenue pour ce premier épisode de
la rentrée où nous allons nous
intéresser à la fameuse disparition des
mayas tout commence par la mission
d'exploration par john lloyd steffens et
fredrik casar woods mené entre 1839 et
ce qui au départ une mission
diplomatique permet finalement la re
découverte de plusieurs cités perdues
certains sites avait déjà été décrit par
des voyageurs tel que celui de copan par
un colonel de l'armée guatémaltèque
quelques années plus tôt mais tout cela
reste assez confidentiel pour le grand
public et c'est là que notre case aroud
intervient il est dessinateur et
aquarelliste il a voyagé au moyen-orient
et ses panoramas de ruines antiques ont
déjà fasciné le public londonien
ces lithographies dessins et peintures
sont publiées dans un ouvrage infidels
of travel in central américain et montre
ses ruines antiques déserté aux
inscriptions étrange c'est vraiment à
partir de ce moment là que le public est
conquis et se passionne pour la
mystérieuse disparition des mayas les
récits farfelu vont très vite arrivé et
pour n'en citer qu'un celui de james
churchward en 1932 qui fait de ces
ruines
l'oeuvre des habitants du mythique
continent de mu essayons de comprendre
cette fascination
à la différence des aztèques les grandes
cités mayas n'ont pas été attaquées par
les espagnols xvième siècle elle était
déjà abandonné à cette époque et c'est
pourquoi elles ont pu incarner un
certain mystère pour une fois les héros
père n'y était pour rien et on avait là
des sites archéologiques pure en quelque
sorte
il n'y a donc pas de grands récits
détaillés de la conquête comme celui de
bernal díaz del castillo pour les
aztèques
on a bien des archives sur les conquêtes
notamment celle du dernier royaume itza
à la toute fin du xviie siècle
mais cette histoire reste assez peu
diffusés la raison principale de cet
engouement teinté de mystère pour les
mayas et à mon avis
le décalage entre ces imposant vestige
qui appelle une explication et l'absence
de récits historiques aussi linéaire que
celui des aztèques
ces derniers ont d'ailleurs été conquis
en deux ans rien de tel pour les mayas
mais tout ça ça nous donne pas les
raisons de cette disparition de nombreux
auteurs pas tous archéologues d'ailleurs
comme jared diamond dont je reparlerai
tout à l'heure se sont penchés sur cette
question
mais avant d'aller plus loin je vais
vous donner quelques repères
chronologiques les ruines qui servent de
support à notre imaginaire sont de la
période dite classique s'étendant entre
300 et 900 après jésus-christ ce qui
correspond à notre au moyen-âge en
quelque sorte à la fin de la période les
sites et des basses terres capital des
grands royaumes périclite tandis que le
nord de la péninsule du yucatan prospère
un temps avant de sombrer à son tour
l'effondrement de la civilisation
classique a été un véritable aiguillon
pour la recherche scientifique et cela a
engendré de nombreux débats chez les
spécialistes et dans toutes les théories
que j'ai pu lire à ce sujet et bien on
peut distinguer quelques facteurs
principaux
les archéologues constate un état de
guerre généralisée à la fin de la
période
on voit les villages se fortifier les
installations humaines recherche les
relief pour se retrancher ont bâti de
vastes réseaux de murailles et il semble
que toute la société est été affectée
par de graves conflits l'organisation du
monde maya en cité état rival est en
effet propice au conflit les élites
royal tente par ce moyen d'acquérir du
prestige mais est ce que ça aurait pu
dégénérer au point de faire disparaître
les royaumes d'autres scientifiques ont
avancé l'hypothèse de guerre externes
notamment des invasions par l'ouest du
pays
car on voit de nouveaux styles de
poterie qui apparaissent notamment à
cette époque alors le coup de la poterie
ça peut sembler insignifiant mais c'est
bien souvent un indice d'invasion pour
les archéologues
mais cette dernière hypothèse est en
partie abandonnée de nos jours grâce aux
travaux archéologiques la mutation
observée c'est probablement déroulé sur
place autre théorie un grave changement
climatique serait survenu en traînant
sécheresse famine et donc de violente
guerre pour le contrôle des ressources
les analystes d'arkeon environnementale
donne une nouvelle fois contre eux dans
ce schéma aucune trace de cataclysme
environnemental seulement quelques
épisodes difficiles mais leurs liens
avec les effondrements est incertain
alors la pression sur l'environnement
c'est une théorie populaire mettant en
avant la surpopulation qui aurait
entraîné une surexploitation de la forêt
et des sols ces phénomènes de
dégradation de l'environnement sont
identifiés à plusieurs endroits mais ne
semble encore une fois pas suffisant
pour leur faire porter seul la
responsabilité de l'effondrement
classique
jared diamond qui consacre aux mayas le
chapitre 5 de son best-seller
effondrement met l'accent sur ses causes
environnementales notamment sur la
déforestation
conséquence de la fabrication du stuc
qui servait à blanchir les temples le
stuc c'est un enduit à base de chaux
il faut donc brûlé de très grande
quantité de calcaire pour oxyder le
calcium qu'il contient et donc ça
demande un approvisionnement en bois
très très important l'ornementation
croissante des temples qui prenait part
à la rivalité entre les cités pourraient
avoir causé de graves déforestation
entraînant des glissements de terrain un
appauvrissement des sols une baisse de
précipitations etc etc
voilà pour trois causes qui ont pu
influer en se combinant sans doute sur
le déclin de la civilisation urbaine
médiévale maya et les survivants à
toutes ces crises eh bien il n'était pas
au bout de leur peine et je continue la
liste en effet comme les autres peuples
amérindiens les mayas ont été gravement
touchés par les épidémies européenne
restait sans contact avec le vieux monde
pendant des millénaires les indiens ne
se sont pas adaptés aux microbes et
autres virus qui ont affecté les
européens africains et asiatiques dans
ce laps de temps
alors qu'en arrivant 15 111 dans l'est
du yucatan une chaloupe de naufragés
d'espagnol une grave épidémie ravages
rapidement la région
quand les européens entament la conquête
des dernières principauté maya elles
sont déjà très lourdement affaibli par
ces nouvelles maladies
je viens d'en parler et à cela il faut
ajouter de véritable épisode de conquête
espagnole qui viennent en quelque sorte
finir le travail à partir de 15 124
francisco des monteiro et pedro des
alvarado deux compagnons de cortés qui
ont participé à la prise de mexico même
des expéditions pour contrôler ses
terres et se constituer de grandes
fortunes au nom du roi d'espagne après
avoir listé ses causes
eh ben on est à peine plus avancé et on
ne peut que conclure que c'est une
conjugaison de facteurs qui a contribué
à cet effondrement
et si on n'arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord sur un facteur qui aurait causé
cette disparition
c'est peut-être tout simplement parce
que les maliens n'ont pas disparu et
quand je dis ça c'est pas qu'il en reste
un ou deux perdus dans la forêt les
mayas n'ont pas disparu du tout le
mexique reste habité par des millions de
maya parlant des dizaines de langues qui
reste très proche de celle que parler
les habitants des fameuses ruines
on s'en rend particulièrement content
quand on prend le métro à mexico
on croise des profils des silhouettes
des visages que l'on retrouve gravé sur
les stèles de palenque ou de chichen
itza les mayas n'ont jamais disparu ils
ont simplement abandonné leur ville
médiévale
donc il faudrait à présent non plus
parler de disparition mais de crise et
même plutôt de crise de la civilisation
urbaine
les facteurs qu'on a décrit plus haut
ont conduit certaines villes maya à être
abandonné mais de nouveaux centres
urbains ont émergé par la suite
peut-être pas bâti en pierre avec
d'immenses temple blanchis à la chaux
mais ces villes étaient bien là les
espagnols qui ont dû les assiégés
pourrait en témoigner
si certaines villes ont été abandonnées
bas ça n'a pas forcément été le cas pour
les campagnes environnantes qui pouvait
rester très peuplée une fois les grands
royaumes urbain disparu eh bien les
problèmes qu'on a listé disparaissent
avec eux plus besoin de faire la guerre
pour des chefs assoiffés de pouvoir plus
besoin de ravagé les forêts pour des
prêtres mégalo retour à la bonne vieille
principauté paysanne qui pètent pas plus
haut que son cul mais du coup n'a pas
trop mal à survivre
les habitants ont sans doute fui les
villes et leurs conflits permanents pour
se réfugier dans les campagnes où de
nouvelles cités secondaire les mayas
n'ont pas disparu parce qu'ils avaient
encore la possibilité de vivre hors des
villes
et ce sont en définitive ces éléments
urbains les plus fragiles de leurs
sociétés qui ont succombé à cette grande
crise quand on y pense c'est un peu
effrayant dans notre cas au 21ème siècle
la grande majorité d'entre nous aurait
bien du mal s'il fallait vivre sans
ville pour se nourrir ou pour se loger
par exemple si on pense souvent que les
mayas ont disparu c'est qu'encore une
fois ce que l'on retient de leur
histoire est uniquement ce qui nous
intéresse
une affaire de mystère de grands
bouleversements ou de re découverte
sensationnelle par de courageuses
explorateurs la vérité comme souvent est
beaucoup plus complexe et moins sexy
comme j'espère avoir réussi à vous le
faire entrevoir
c'est la fin de cet épisode j'espère
qu'il vous a plu vous pouvez le partager
et vous abonner à la chaîne est
également poser vos questions aux
commentaires j'y répondrai avec plaisir
enfin si vous voulez me soutenir c'est
sûr typique ça se passe le lien est ici
dans le petit ou en barre d'infos et sur
la page d'accueil de ma chaîne à bientôt